MONKEY JUMPED A CEREMONIAL FIRST
PUCK BEFORE MY FIRST
THEY GET IT BACK.
IT TRIES TO PUT IT THROUGH THE
BOX, GETS ABACK TRACK THE PUCK
AND HE'S TAKING THREE STEPS TO
THE RIGHT, THREE IS NOT.
THAT'S CAME RIGHT OUT INTO THE T
SEVEN OVERALLS.
IT DEFINITELY FEELING A LOT MORE
COMFORTABLETHE DEFENDER.OND BRIT
HIGH.
OVER TOER THE LEFT IS THAT I COH
NINE SECONDS STILL LEFT ONTHE
ZONE.
THE RED WINGS HAVE THE SECONDIND
SMITH.
RECOVERED IN THE TYLER BERTUZZIK
JUST FINDS THEM.
AS HE PINCHES, HIT BY BENEWAH
THE PUCK IS PICKED.
>> THEY WILL PUT.
ACROSS THE LINE GOT OVER TO RICK
KRALL AND WHAT A PASS AND H HIS
LEGS, AND ACTUALLY BOUNCES OFF
HIS SKATE IS ZEGRAS
AS HE CARRIES ON.
IT TRIES TO CUT TO THE MIDDLE
AND JUST ALLUDED A BIG HIT THE E
CIRCLES.
GETTING IT BACK. ENERGIES OF THE
DOWN TERRY DON'T HAVE
A LOT LEFT OUT THERE RIGHT NOW.
RIGHT NOW TO THE FUN
GOAL LINE. FACE-OFF BEFORE,
DISCUSSING WITH FOWLER DAY.
FOR PLAYERS TO BEICULT.
>> GET LUCAS HIS
FIRST NHL WIN IF HE CAN SCAR
RIGHT